el sacro imperio romano era un grupo de
religiones en europa central constituido
por una alianza política el sacro
imperio romano se formó en el año 900 62
si x representa años escribe una
desigualdad relacionando x con 962 que
representen los años antes de la
formación del sacro imperio romano bien
nos están pidiendo que escribamos una
desigualdad que involucre a x ya 962
pero revisemos con cuidado nos están
diciendo que el sacro imperio romano se
formó en el 900 62 y nos están pidiendo
que la desigualdad represente en los
años antes de la formación del sacro
imperio romano y utilicemos x para
representarlo
así que x tendrá que ser
en 962 pues es el tiempo antes de la
formación del sacro imperio romano a ver
escribamos ya tenemos la equis ahora
pongo un menor que y luego 962 ya
tenemos x menor que 962 y comprobamos
nuestra respuesta bien hagamos otra
muy bien ahora tenemos este problema el
año es 1.207 y los mongoles al mando de
gengis khan invaden china el ejercito
mongol tiene 75.000 soldados y los
mongoles tendrán una victoria decisiva
si el número de soldados chinos es menor
que el de los suyos si x representa el
número de soldados chinos escribe una
desigualdad a ver vamos a marcarlo
escribe una desigualdad en términos de x
y 75.000 que represente una victoria
decisiva para las fuerzas mongolas y
analicemos el problema nos están
diciendo que el ejército mongol tiene 75
mil soldados y para obtener una victoria
el número de soldados chinos tendrá que
ser menor a este número x representa a
los soldados chinos así que no esta
desigualdad
y detener a x que son los soldados
chinos y su número tendrá que ser menor
que el ejército mongol que tiene 75.000
soldados así que escribiremos x menor
que 75.000
comprobemos nuestra respuesta perfecto